at this time we will now begin with
chief castle thank you
good afternoon everybody uh greg castle
here for the uh meeting
just giving you a quick update and
overview of where we're at uh as of
today
as of february 16th uh 2021 we have
given
304 109 vaccines in clark county
to include 239 241 first doses
and 64 868 second doses
those doses are being distributed in
phases according to the center of
disease control prevention
centers for disease control and
prevention and the governor's
uh behavioral health uh covert
vaccination playbook
anybody who needs to schedule these
appointments can go to the health
district
website uh or and schedule for those
locations at sn www.snhd.info
covid those appointments are made three
days in advance
depending on vaccine availability with
that said
vaccine availability has become a
problem for us as it has across many
places
in the nation right now due to the
severe weather we are not receiving we
did not receive our shipment of moderna
for this week and beginning tomorrow we
are not going to be able to give any
second dose vaccinations to people in
need of those second dose
moderna shots those people are going to
be rescheduled for a new appointment
we have put together a new call center
that will go active in the morning
and begin contacting people letting them
know uh that not only their their
equipment has to be rescheduled
but they're going to actively reschedule
that group or those people
for an appointment hopefully at the same
time same day just one week later
this is not an issue because the the
medicine
can be given within a window up to uh
almost 40 days
if needed so it's not that the vaccine
is not going to be good for you
we just try to target those other days
of 21 and 28 days for their respective
brands
to allow a little cushion and that's the
the parameters that they
are ideal but it's not going to affect
anybody's immunization
because it's often weak we did get our
pfizer vaccines
in our shipments so there's been no
delays in any of the appointments
or problems related with by with pfizer
next week the health district because of
this uh situation
is going to be administered mistering
only second dose vaccines
we are ramping up our capacity at both
convention center and the catchment
center
and the health district site on decatur
to accommodate the people that are
re scheduled from this week and the
people that are coming online next week
that need
second dose vaccines there is a change
in one of our
operating days cashman center is not
going to be open on tuesday
because we have some scheduled training
as we
begin to switch over to the state's
sales force
computer system that's going to be a big
help in the long run for all of us as
far as scheduling
and tracking across the entire state
um we have the capacity to vaccinate
everybody who receives
a first dose once we get those doses in
we're not shorted
we're just delayed in our delivery right
now we do have a significant problem
with people going online and appointment
shopping
booking multiple appointments at even
either convention center
or cashman or other locations going
walmart's and whatever
and then they just don't cancel those
appointments when once they get
they get their vaccine literally up to
ten thousand of those were
identified last week and it's very
problematic we have
3 300 appointments a day set at one of
our sites
and we're averaging about 22 to 2300 uh
people actually showing up
because those people don't show up for
their their appointments for whatever
reason
we know a lot of that is that it's
double bookings
so please do not do that if you have
extra appointments please cancel them
if you've already got your shot and you
had pending appointments anywhere at a
grocery store at a pharmacy or one of
our facilities
please cancel that and open that
opportunity up for somebody else to get
in the line
uh if you're going to get an email or a
or a
appointment verification coming back
once somebody gets rescheduled
they will get an email but if you don't
get an email please check your
spam or junk folders because sometimes
that does not make it through the
filters
and falls into those those locations on
your computer
so that's pretty much my update for
right now where we're at
any questions is it time for questions
jennifer this is my first time in your
forum so i'm not sure how that plays out
chief steinbeck or joanne do you have
anything else to add before we move on
to questions
no i think greg covered it um
we are concerned about the
the supply chain issues but we knew that
that was
was possible and we we really wish that
we had more supply here in the valley
for
at least to be able to absorb those type
of supply chain issues but
we get the shipments when they come in
and and
are not allowed to have any extra uh
standing
inventory to absorb these type of
situations so
that's uh that's the rule book that that
we currently are following
and um we apologize to everybody that's
going to be inconvenienced
from the supply chain problem
yes this is uh joanne ruper director of
clinical services
and yes i want i uh very disappointing
that we did not get our modern shipment
this week
um typically comes on either monday or
tuesday
and we are not expecting it
um until later this week
we i do want to say a great thank you to
all those
of our community partners who have
really helped us out so far in
being able to provide vaccine yesterday
and today
we we did they were able to
lend us some vaccines so that we could
keep operations
going but right now as for tomorrow
thursday and saturday we just don't have
the vaccine available right now
to vaccinate those individuals so
anyone with a moderna appointment will
need to be rescheduled
at this time we will move on to
questions from members of the media
um as mentioned earlier if you have a
question just use the raise hand feature
our first question today comes from mr
john traynor i am a muting
sir thanks all uh we got calls from
people who had gone to
get their second dose at a different
location than they got their initial
dose and they were turned away
my question is if somebody gets their
first dose through
snhd can they go and then go get their
second dose
somewhere else from a private place
whether that be a grocery store or a
clinic
right that is um the issue with that is
whoever gives the first dose can order
the second dose so
if we give 5000 first doses we can order
5 000 second doses
if we give that dose to someone who
didn't get a dose from us
then that could be an issue we're
basically giving that vaccine away to
someone else
so yes they do need to go back to their
original providers
there's been a few instances where um
either for example a person lost their
job at their employer
or some other extenuating circumstances
we can help them out but as a general
rule they need to go back to the
original person
thank you the next question is from
brianna erickson
unmuting you now there you go oh thank
you
um my question is how do you determine
whether
someone in a particular occupational
category
is actually a frontline worker
and yeah how do you determine that at
the sites
um i i think i heard your question i had
a hard time hearing but
how do you determine how if they're the
occupational worker in the correct
categories or groups at
the sites is that what you mean yeah she
was just
how do we verify that sure so uh we have
uh we use
the nevada's playbook
as our guide and we look at all the
different categories and definitions
underneath there is some room for
interpretation but
usually we determine who would be
eligible for the clinics and who would
not and so then at the clinic
our frontline workers check to see if
they're in that occupational group or
not
next question today comes from mary
hines
please go ahead
hi thank you um can you hear me okay
yes yes okay great thank you
what is your best estimate as to when
those 65 to 69
will be eligible to be vaccinated in
clark county
and also what is the process for
determining
when a new occupational group or
public group will be eligible
well for those two topics it could be
pretty much the same answer we we're
going to be
led by the governor's task force on
covid when they determine that we've got
to a certain point that's comfortable to
make any kind of moves like that
they will put that out and as districts
and providers we will adjust accordingly
and then information out to the public
uh our change in operation
and and so forth
and next up is jacqueline schultz from
fox5
hi guys um wanted to uh
if someone or joanna if you could also
clarify a little bit further on
uh it's thursday and saturday that the
second
dose appointments are going to be
canceled uh and then
uh and then rescheduled the same time
frame but my
big question um is i had heard
that the people who uh
or the seventh case of the uk variant
was
someone from out of town an
international traveler from
uh french polynesia who possibly caught
it
here uh and then had trouble getting
back abroad because of well uh
being found with the uk variant if you
could expound on
uh the seventh case of the
uh person with the uk variant
i do not have knowledge of that uh of
that case
uh i'm pretty much in vaccine
operations so that would have to be
i i believe you could follow up with
jennifer on that question
and then we can get uh you know uh
some guidance from our epidemiology
department
before we move on um since we couldn't
hear brianna's question earlier
very clearly she was actually wondering
how do we determine
whether someone in a particular
occupation occupational category is
actually a frontline worker
rather than you know say a back office
worker type of thing
well we we send uh communication
to those industries or or groups
and we we have them
uh communicate to their front line
workers who would be eligible
we do not um ask questions
at the front line specifically
what their role is i mean we we ask
that uh people um
be forthright with their uh
with their information and uh go forward
from that
does that answer your question
hope so okay let's go on to miss andrew
or i'm sorry astrid mendes i'm unmuting
you now
hi how's it going i think um part of the
question is
where exactly are we standing right now
there's a lot of confusion with
not only um you know the frontline
workers but also which
people from other industries are able or
not
to get an appointment now um so i
definitely would like some clarification
in that
where exactly and who exactly right now
is able to get
an appointment um either in one of the
two
um lines that have been described at the
nevada playbook
and also i would like to know more a
little bit about
what happens uh you know with those
vaccines in case that
somebody that was scheduled for them
either at one of the snhd
locations or at a pharmacy and if people
don't show up what happens in those
cases like do they go to waste do they
reach out to other people
how is that working to ensure that the
vaccines are not
going away so there are basically two
things in here
okay so i'll answer the question about
the second doses
and if people don't return we just keep
it
until the state or cdc gives us guidance
on what to do with that vaccine
so there may be extra vaccine in our
refrigerators
right now or freezers that we keep
until uh we are uh given more guidance
on that so
we're it's in a waiting period we don't
we don't have to
um waste it because it it's in the
freezer
and can be kept for about six months so
it's
we only draw up vaccine at each clinic
according to who comes through the door
um for the um the lanes that we have
we're at 70 and up
in the in the um what do they call that
land here
general population for frontline
essential workforce
we are right still at frontline
community support
under continuity of governance and
that's where we are right now
this community support frontline staff
is is kind of confusing so frontline
workers
who support food shelter court legal
and social services and other
necessities of life for needy groups and
individuals
so that is the basis for most of uh who
we
are we have guidance on who can get the
vaccine
for example um shelters
um people who work at wic
social services uh some utility workers
that may
be involved in keeping the lights on and
the
water going for uh individuals
and um shelters those
those are the types of front line
workers we're talking about
as well as education and of course
those front line educators staff and
students for nch
does that clarify if there's a specific
question
about a particular group we can
explore that
i was just going to add something
briefly that at the
at the sites i know you asked how
they're verified
um certainly for the first shot
verification specifically uh
you will be asked if you're if you're uh
if you're going down the
um that lane the uh
the occupational lane or um
then you'll be asked for a work id
or a pay stub or some sort of
verification
as to your employment and that's what
they actively
do
we're going to proceed through all the
people who have got their first time
questions we'll circle back
um if time allows for any follow-ups our
next person know is david charns i'm
meeting you now thank you
um good afternoon everybody um my
question
is for director rupert
in the data that's presented on the
website in terms of
where people are getting the vaccine
it correct me if i'm wrong but the
reported vaccine frequency by zip code
is where people live that are getting
the vaccine not the vaccine
we're not where the vaccines are being
um given out correct so these are
correct
okay so when you look at that map um
[Music]
this is something that was talked about
at another
call and something that the governor has
talked about i mean
the areas that uh areas of the valley
where people are living below the
poverty line
seems to be rather low in frequency
so what is the health district doing if
anything to make sure that
the vaccine is being distributed
equitably
um because you know that you look at
this map and
in the southwest uh southeast and north
and northwest are doing pretty well
where northeast which are communities
of working class folk
[Music]
are seemingly not getting the vaccine so
can you speak a little to that
sure um so if you look at uh who we've
been
immunizing first it was the um
health care workers and uh first
responders
and uh police force so um
it may be that reason why their
those zip codes were uh are more highly
vaccinated than others um
frontline community support we're
talking education
um the um
frontline workers who support social
services county
type of workers that may account for
some of that
and then on the age group it's 70 and up
so
when you look at a
map of age groups
for the county those age groups are also
in that
area in those areas so
that may account for why there is a
discrepancy
so far i will tell you we've had clinics
in the other zip codes targeting
those populations and for example we
did in our own if you notice uh
89107 is our zip code for the health
district so
we did um assist a neighbor uh
of um elderly residents to come and get
their vaccine
and we've also had um clinics in
those zip codes as well and we've had
pretty good
uh response so we'll continue to do that
work
and uh we're also
uh we're also in partnership with
unionized nevada
and uh we have a reach grant that will
also reach out to those
uh communities uh the hispanic and the
african-american
communities to encourage them to come
and get vaccine
um there may be other reasons why they
they would not want to
get vaccine as we've i've talked before
some people are more hesitant than
others
and there may be different reasons maybe
a personal
experience maybe a group experience that
um you know uh makes them
hesitant to get vaccine so uh
so that's those are the types of things
that we've been doing
i'd like to add on to that too joanne if
i may um
the sites we've had over the last
several weeks
are dead set in the middle of those
areas that you're trying to speak of el
dorado high school
desert pines hollywood recreational
center mack middle school
parkdale recreation center cora coleman
etc
plus cashmen and convention center are
both located in locations that are
you know meet the demographic groups
that you're speaking of we've also
worked with many elected officials
uh from various boards and commissions
and councils
that have gone out in canvas and
neighborhoods trying to get people to
sign up for this and that's had some
mixed results
we've had as little as uh been able to
fill fifty percent of vacant spots
uh open for certain sites uh but at one
point in time or another we have to open
those sites up to the rest of the
community so if we have
say 300 uh appointments closed
for trying to target seniors and people
in those particular areas
but only 140 of them sign up we owe it
to the rest of the community to open up
those 160 spots to whoever meets those
tiers
and they will drive we've had people
from some of our sites here in town have
people from out of town show up because
they're allowed to do so so we have done
our very best to target that and we are
still
working on that we will continue to work
on that but once things progress and we
get into some different tiers
i anticipate those numbers will switch
thank you chief we're gonna take one
more question now from michelle price
i'm meeting you now
uh hi this is michelle price with ap i
have two questions i'm just wondering on
the
moderna uh second dose appointments that
have to be postponed
how many people are we talking about
roughly
um and then generally for the uh
problem we're having with people making
multiple appointments and not canceling
them how do we know that that's what's
going on have we been able to contact
them or
do we have some way to check to find out
that they got a vaccine somewhere else
right well we can pull reports on all of
our appointments for the day
and we do have a number that were
canceled uh we really
don't know if they we don't have the
capability to
know if they showed up or not um that
it has a that would take us
more sophisticated i.t than we have
right now so
uh we have difficulty doing that so um
yeah i mean i think uh we had
our platform was not the best
uh in the beginning for canceling
appointments and that's part of the
issue
and um and the and the issue for the
second dose
is we have not been able to schedule it
right away
immediately when they make the first
dose appointment so
we have to wait until they complete
their first dose before we can
schedule their second dose so
there have been challenges of that as
well
thank you joanne our last question today
will come from michael scott davidson
any follow-ups or clarifications please
send those to the office of
communications
at this time we're taking mr davidson's
call
hi there thank you um given what
happened
with the temporary break in the supply
chain
with the modernity doses um you know i
think to how the state of nevada's
strategy for ordering second doses is
to just order what they need for the
week ahead the coming week given that
we've now seen an incident here where we
see a break in the supply chain
that because we don't have those doses
in the state has caused us to
push back appointments i'm wondering if
the southern nevada health district or
uh anybody in our team right now is you
know considering whether asking the
state to perhaps
change its strategy to get more second
doses inside the state
than we absolutely need for the next
week ahead so that if there is a break
in the supply chain for whatever reason
we won't encounter a problem again like
we're encountering right now
yes we've had multiple um discussions
with the state on this and keep in mind
that
the federal um the it's actually federal
that makes the rules for most of the
vaccine distribution
so um the state um and we have had
conversations about having more of a
supply only
on on hand and
that may be i hope we can do this in the
future
that is yet to be determined on how much
we can't keep
on the shelves uh so we're really hoping
that that can be
um that that will be definitely the case
we've had about we had to schedule about
5 000
doses for the for these next three days
thursday friday saturday and we'll be
rescheduling those next week
we're focusing on all second doses next
week
and so we really hope to get most of
the people that need or that are coming
back for their second dose can get that
second dose
we also have a clinic this week um
for at desert pines that is also doing
pfizer second doses so
um what my ops team wanted to make sure
that you were aware of that
and people can walk into that one and
that
information is on our website
yes michael i'll add to that just a
little bit as well uh it's exactly what
joanne said
we're very grateful to the state and to
the feds for every dose that we get
operationally speaking it's very
difficult to plan
when you're not positive on what's
coming in and you're in a
week to week an even narrower type of
scheduling but
the the priority was to get the doses
out into the community as quickly as
possible and then
deal with fallout if if they don't come
and so
we understand that but on our side we
would
we would it would be much
easier and more efficient if we were
working off of a
supply that was currently in the valley
and we could plan
a week in advance instead of days in
advance